اشكركم على ضيفتكم الحرد ونشكر صاحب السمو
الملكي والعهد محمد بن سلمان
للشعب السعودي هو مدينه جده التي تستضيف
هذه القمه
كلنا هنا من اجل السلام والعداله ايها
المشاركون الكرام
اليوم
هو اليوم 450 من الحرب الشامله التي ضدنا
من قبل الغازات الروسي صواريخها كما
يمتلكها العدو والجنها قوه جويه اضعف ولا
نمتلك
المسيرات القاتله العديده التي تزودها
ايران لروسيا
وليس لدينا الكثير من المدفعيه ولكننا
صامدون لان
الحق
الى جانبنا وعلاوه على ذلك فان نحن ندفع
المحتله خارج بلادنا كل من يدافع عن ارضه
في وجه الغزاه وكل من يدافع عن اطفال امته
من الاستعباد
كل محاربه ذلك يسير على طريق العداله وانا
فخور لان امثله حول المقاتلين الابطال
والشعب الاوكراني باكمله
الاوكرانيون
لم يختاروا الحرب ابدا جنودنا
لم يغزوا اراضيها اخرى ونحن لا ننخرط في
عملياتي
او انتهاك لمصادر دول الاخرى ولكننا لن
نخضع ابدا
لاي عدو او مستعمر ولهذا فنحن نقاتل وانا
متاكده من كل دول تتفهم لذلك وانا متاكد
ان اموركم
تتفهم كلمتي التي وهو نداء نبيله لكم
جميعا المساعده في حمايه شعبنا من ضمنهم
حتى الجاليه الاوكرانيه معي هنا
مصطفى جميل
قائد اهل الشعب الفتري من القرمه
ومن السكان الاصليين لاوكرانيا وطنهم
القرمه في مركز الثقافه الاسلاميه في
اوكرانيا
لقرون وترى اوكرانيين
جزء لا يتجزا من الجاليه المستوى
والمسلمين في العالم ولكن
القرن تعاني من احتلال الروسي والى الان
فاغلب هؤلاء
الخاضعين القمع في القرن المحتله من
المسلمين
تجربه ايجابيه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ثم يخصون اطلاقي صلاحيه الاسرى الذين
اسرتهم روسيا او بامكاننا
او حتى وان كان هنالك في هذه القمه ناديهم
بوجهه نظر مختلفه حول الحرب على ارضنا
ويسمونها نزاعا فانا متاكد من اننا نستطيع
ان نتوحد من اجل انقاذ الاشخاص من اقفاص
السجون الروسيه
للاسف هنالك حول العالم ممن غض النظر عن
تلك الاقفاص وعمليات الضم غير القانونيه
وانا هنا
لكي يلقي الجميع نظره صادقه على الامر
مهما حاول الروس التاثير يجب ان يكون
هنالك استقلالا
ومن وجهه نظرية اود ان اشكر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه واغلبيتكم على دعمنا
ودعم المواقف الدوليه وميثاق الامم
المتحده ايها المشاركون الكرام
انتم تعرفون بين شعب اوكرانيا وشعب سلام
في عام 2021
اولوياتنا كانت
متفتحه لشعوبكم ولشعب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده
وعمان والبحرين والكويت
تعرفوا على اوكرانيا بشكل جيد وانا سعيد
للسياحه كم شاهدوا
جمال عاصمه
القرن الاوكرانيه الحره من الاحتلال
الروسي
علاقاتنا ايضا متجذره
بتعليم عشرات الالاف من طلب العرب في
جامعاتنا في كل عام
ويشرفنا ان الاطفال من المغرب ومصر
والاردن والعراق ولبنان والجزائر وليبيا
وتونس
درسوا في اوكرانيا معكم نحن
سنشاهد من جوني
القتالي كيف العدو
اطفالكم الذين يتم ترحيلهم الى روسيا
ويفصلون عنها اغربهم وهم في روسيا يحاولون
تعليم اطفالنا
كراهيه
اهاليهم وانا متاكد من ان لا احد منكم
الاحتلال العسكري لمحطه نوويه لاستخدامها
من اجل ابتزاز العالم بكارثه نوويه جديده
انظروا
تم من المعاناه اثرت الحروب على ليبيا
وسوريا وكم من الحيوانات زهقت بعد سنوات
من القتال في السودان والصومال والعراق
وافغانستان
كل من يزيد من المعاناه باعتداءاته
الجديده
او كل من يحيطها العداوه
ويريد ان يعيد
ايام الامبراطوريات الغازيه التي
تفرض ارادتها على الدول المستقله كل ما
تدي يواجه العالم وسوف يحكم عليه في
الختام وانا
احيي كل من قرر في مسار العداله اوكرانيا
اخترع حتى معادله السلام من اجل انهاء
الحرب بامكانكم ان تروا كيف انها تنطق على
الامن الغذائي واحده من نقاط معادلتنا حتى
عندما فرضت الحرب على اراضينا فنحن ندرك
نتاكد من الصمود البقيه من خلال تزويدنا
للحبوب عبر مبادره البحر الاسود
يجب ان يرفع رؤوس حصار من البحريه على
موالينا
احاديث تساعد في تحقيق الاستقرار لاسواقها
الغذاء ومساعده العديد من دول جامعه الدول
العربيه ان التطبيق نقطه اخرى معادله
تضمن العوده الى الاوطان لكافه الاسرى
والمراحلين وكل واحد
من الاعضاء المشاركين ومن يحاول ثقه بلغته
بعشر نقاط من هذه المعادله بامكانكم
اختيار
النقاط التي ترون انها مناسبه
وساكون ممتنه لكل واحد منكم من
يختار اتجاه انقاذ ارواح الناس في الاسرار
الروسي لذلك يدعوكم جميعا
معادله السلام هذه وبالتالي
لانهائه العداوه
والحرب او الشرق روسيا ضعيفه هزمناها حتى
مع انها تمتلك عدد اكبر من الاسلحه في
ايديها ان اعدائيتها لا تاتي من القوه بل
من فهمهم ان زمن الامبراطوريات
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات